during winters it gets difficult to  drive because of smog smog is basically  a combination of smoke and fog but why  can't we see beyond it isn't it just  blue today the reason we are unable to  see beyond smoke fog or smog is because  they are colloids in simple words a  colloid is any substance consisting of  particles substantially larger than  atoms or ordinary molecules but too  small to be visible to the unaided eye  so what happens in smog is that carbon  particles for example burnt wood or  paper etc are suspended in the air they  don't completely mix with air and can be  filtered easily from it  but these particles block our vision and  it becomes difficult to see  other examples of colloids are aerosol  sprays mist mayonnaise butter cheese  dust do you know the most common method  used for separating colloids please  share your answers in the comment  section below  [Music]